so let's get to yesterday's testimony do
not allow yourselves to be tricked by
Donald Trump writing in huge sharpie no
quid pro quo we'll get to that sharpie
later yesterday's testimony from Gordon
Sunland confirmed the quid pro quo
bribery extortion Ukraine deal working
through Rudy Giuliani on the behalf of
Donald Trump when asked he you
ambassador Gordon Sandlin said in the
most explosive testimony thus far yes
there was a quid pro quo involving
politically motivated smear
investigations into Joe Biden and hunter
Biden getting Ukraine a meeting with
Trump was part of it military aid was
thrown in there but even more
importantly maybe Sunland has thrown
everyone under the bus saying Mike
Pompeo knew what was going on Rudy
Giuliani was central to what was going
on sunlen said everyone was in the loop
Mike Pence knew Mick Mulvaney knew
Sunland said they were all in on it
let's look at two key Clips starting
with this one
I don't intend to repeat my prior
opening statement or attempt to
summarize 10 hours of previous
deposition testimony however a few
critical points have been obscured by
noise over the last few days and weeks
and I'm worried that the bigger picture
is being ignored so let me make a few
key points first secretary Perry
ambassador Volcker and I worked with mr.
Rudy Giuliani on Ukraine matters at the
express direction of the President of
the United States we did not want to
work with mr. Giuliani simply put we
were playing the hand we were dealt we
all understood that if we refused to
work with mr. Giuliani we would lose a
very important opportunity to cement
relations between the United States and
Ukraine so we followed the president's
orders Rudy Giuliani was imposed
done them by Donald Trump and the
keyline of course the quid pro quo I
know that members of this committee
frequently framed these complicated
issues in the form of a simple question
was there a quid pro quo as I testified
previously with regard to the requested
White House call and the White House
meeting the answer is yes mr. Giuliani
conveyed to secretary Perry ambassador
Volcker and others that President Trump
wanted a public statement from president
Solinsky committing to investigations of
burry smih and the 2016 election
Sunland admits he worked on this for
Trump Rudy told him let's pressure
Ukraine to announce these investigations
remember that Donald Trump first called
sunland a really good man when it looked
like Sunland was going to be useful to
Trump but now Trump is distancing saying
this is not a man I know well it's funny
I tweeted let me see if I can even pull
it up because I had a moment where I
sort of summed it up in a way I thought
was interesting Sunland was hired by
Trump who hires the best people which is
why Trump said we could believe Sunland
at first but then when it became clear
Sunland was saying things damaging to
Trump this is why we elected Trump to
get people like Sunland out of
government who Trump barely knows how
quickly the story changes as we have all
very very quickly learned with Donald
Trump now another general area of
concern here which hasn't been discussed
much since the song won testimony
yesterday is that the degree to which
Rudy Giuliani as an unelected private
person is doing the bidding of the
president internationally including even
directing American ambassadors about
what to do is truly disgusting and
concerning in and of itself Rudy is
representing Trump's wants and his and
desires and needs around the world and
he's no one I mean in the end he's
Trump's TV lawyer he is a lawyer in the
sense that many people with law degrees
in the u.s. become effectively lobbyists
and peddlers of political influence and
Rudy is traveling around the world
telling ambassadors what to do which
country to pressure who to lean on what
the deliverables are that are expected
and it is of course something that
Republicans will do everything possible
not to discuss instead focusing on
attacking Gordon sunland's credibility
and whether they succeed at doing that
depends on what you were open to be
leaving now hilariously at one point
Scott Perry who's a Republican
criticized sunland for listening to what
Rudy said over what Donald Trump said
which is hilarious because Rudy was
there for Donald Trump the Republicans
some realizing you know this unelected
guy Rudy Giuliani traveling around
having meetings with people he's not
Senate confirmed he's really directing
people at a very high level to do this
that or the other thing for Donald Trump
that doesn't look good they realized
that it doesn't look good and Perry said
well you're in the wrong Gordon Sandlin
because you were listening to Rudy
instead of the president well the whole
point is Rudy was there to communicate
the desires of the president in a way
that at least least put like you know
half half a layer of separation even
though it's obvious why Rudy was there
it was one of the most flaccid and
transparent attempts to try to criticize
Sunland when really the here's the real
question about Sunland okay the question
about Sandland is is he'll witness here
or is he a co-conspirator like in
listening to the testimony yesterday the
biggest question mark is not did Trump
do it did Trump and Giuliani and all of
them know about it the real question is
should we be seeing Sunland as someone
who is merely reporting what he saw or
is he actually a co-conspirator because
he admits oh no I did this stuff Rudy
told me to do I did the stuff that
Trump's White House had people all over
the world disseminating as what it was
that needs to happen so that's really
the question I came away with Sunland as
a witness or Sunland as a co-conspirator
let me know what you think Republicans
of course wanted to act like sunland's
Testim
he wasn't damaging but at one point it
was amazing the camera flashed to Devin
unas the ranking member on the House
Intelligence himself as Gordon
seunghwan's testimony wrapped up find
that moment we will take a quick break
much more to discuss remember that on
Black Friday we will be emailing
everybody on our mailing list with a
just extraordinary membership special if
you've been thinking about becoming a
supporter of the David Pakman show which
I would encourage you to do quite
frankly I'm biased but I would encourage
you to do it get on our mailing list at
david pakman.com and then on Black
Friday you will get an email with a
super super secret one day use code to
sign up for membership at a an an
obscenely discounted price let me just
put it that way quick break back after
this today's program is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman if
you've not already heard about blink
Asst it's amazing it's an app for your
phone tablet or web browser and what
they do is they take nonfiction books
popular nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good also bunk by
Kevin Young useful in preparing me for
the pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n